[Music]
hi I'm Alex and today I'm going to be
hosting a friendsgiving and I'm gonna be
making at dunks giving tricks it's gonna
be a slam dunk what I'm cooking I love
doing a modern take on classic dishes so
I know putting espresso and a turkey
brine is a little bit different but
espresso is actually a flavor enhancer
so it's just gonna bring out all those
delicious flavors and make for a really
really flavorful turkey so it's my first
time hosting a friendsgiving on my own
I've been helping my mom in the kitchen
on Thanksgiving for years our turkey is
usually so big and it doesn't fit in our
fridge so my mom uses this cooler to
maximize space my fridge is really small
so I'm using it because I just don't
have room I'm gonna be roasting my
turkey of our bed of onions and carrots
even though we've already brined no
Turkey we're gonna be adding even more
flavor with melted butter chicken stock
garlic powder onion powder and some
black pepper
now we're just gonna give the turkey a
little massage just to rub all those
spices in there
I have so much to be thankful for family
friends and of course dunkin lattes and
this year I'm just so excited to share
that with my
[Music]